warning okay i'm starting the meeting
now
and we'll be live in 10 seconds from
this moment
okay
so we are live now we're live now
fine well welcome everyone to this
meeting of cabinet on the 11th of
january
uh i particularly like to welcome david
elkington to his first meeting of
cabinets
and without further ado apologies
oh no do a roll call uh
so can we do a roll call please anne
yeah yourself counselor jefferson if you
can just say that you can see and hear
everything
i can see and hear everything thank you
councillor pemberton i can see and hear
everything
thank you councillor barker councillor
barker i can see and hear everything
thank you councillor cargill council
cargill i can see and hear
everything thank you councillor harvey
uh council harvey can see in here thank
you very much thank you councillor
jennings
councillor jen who's here i can hear and
see can see and hear all the proceedings
thank you councillor kettle
councillor kettle i can see and hear all
proceedings
thank you councillor harry councillor
parry i can hear
and see all the proceedings thank you
thank you councillor shenton
cancer center and i can see and hear all
proceedings thank you
thank you we should also have that
online with those councillors june ed
dixon and o'donnell thank you thank you
uh any just any
apologies for absence and no neither no
fine any disclosures or interest members
of cabinet
i'll take that as a no minutes uh
are the minutes of the previous meeting
uh held on the 7th of december uh
okay for my approval does anyone have
any comments
mr chairman i i did uh give notice that
there was one need for an alteration
in relation to minute 402
second paragraph line three and it
should read
meeting of the cabinet to be held
thank you councillor harvey i'm sure the
minutes can be adjusted to
say that and subject to that amendment
are the minutes okay agreed
thank you before moving on
i think we have an issue with the
cabinet meeting scheduled for the 8th of
february
if i'm correct and that this will now
conflict with potentially conflict with
the
county council budget meeting to be held
on the same day
to be on the safe side can i suggest
that we
uh start the meeting at four o'clock
instead of 3 30
great everyone in agreement with that
agree agreed thank you
uh so without further ado then
moving on uh oh no sorry sorry
tony sorry sorry forgive me mr chairman
i
i couldn't unmute fast enough um
a full if we do have a full council at
wcc
four o'clock might be early enough as
long as there aren't any
funny games played with the budget
meeting would you agree
fellow twin hatters the reason we've
never had one go on that long but they
do sometimes
i wonder whether it would be safer to
say five o'clock but there we go
yeah i mean sometimes the budget goes on
until 10 o'clock at night but um
again it hasn't happened since we've
been there but
uh twin hatters what do you think
mark i agree sorry i'm just unmuting i
agree because it
can't tell it's a piece of string
i would rather see it perhaps another
day but there we go because people keep
because the other groups some of the
other groups tend to have and we do as
well
if there's something contentious we all
go off and have sidebar meetings and boy
does it take a long time these days
i think it would it may be better to put
it put it back into the ninth
i don't know just a suggestion
so we really have a choice between
either putting it on a different day
or having it start at five o'clock is
that about it
even five could be pushing it i'm trying
to remember what time the last one ended
but it was shockingly
forever uh leader my preference would be
for another day only because it's
a it's when you've been on zoom and will
have been on zoom since nine o'clock
i don't believe that um
we're in the best place to then have a
serious cabinet meeting
mr buckland uh are there would there be
any
issues with us trying to rearrange the
date
okay we will try and rearrange today uh
chairman
absolutely if that's impossible because
we were already trying to arrange these
meetings around other meetings
and understand the class for the county
could we say if we can't rearrange it
the do a six o'clock start on
on that day instead i i do hear what
captain parry says so
a full day on the zoom can be very
caring we couldn't have it much later
than the
8th february because we need to make
some recommendations first of all
okay then in that case we've got it if
we can't rearrange the date we start at
six o'clock on the eighth
grade thank you and
what i just want to say as well as um
rearranging the agenda items so that we
are going to go
item 4 next then item 6
then item 7 then item 5
then back to the agenda as printed
okay so without further ado item four
fenney compton neighborhood development
plan
uh councillor pemberton thank you very
much
leader members before you
is the fenney compton neighborhood
development plan
which has now received reached the
pre-submission consultation responses
stage and members of cabinet
you will see at appendix one to your
papers
the schedule of significant comments
from the district council in relation to
the regulation 14
pre-submission consultation version
undertaken by penny compton's parish
council and its
neighborhood development plan project
team
members the recommendation is that the
schedule of
significant comments at appendix one be
endorsed
and submitted to the fenney compton
parish council as the formal response to
the pre-submission
consultation process associated with the
draft fenney compton
neighborhood development plan which is
at appendix 2 in your papers
before doing so i would uh just draw
members to uh
an additional comment um that
in conjunction with uh mr carefort um
i would intend to put on put in our
response under the
minor alterations members are drawn to
the executive summary of
uh the draft neighborhood development
plan
the foot of phage page four um gives an
overview
of the position outlined in the course
strategy as it relates to category
2 local service villages and the
maximums around
the the the notion of 2000 homes
for lsv category 2 villages
highlighted by the examination inspector
members of cabinet will be aware that
both core strategy numbers themselves
are a minimum not a maximum
but also within each of the categories
okay
yes sorry haley just a second
uh
all right shall i just i think i'll just
uh press on yes
whilst uh the the notional 2000 uh
is there and indeed is reflected in the
policy document itself which does
allow for uh support of
development within the built-up area
boundary uh that position is not
outlined in the executive summary and it
has been brought to my attention that it
would be tidier
if the executive summary reflected the
position that's in the policy statement
on page 27
and so with cabinet's agreement i would
intend to have that as a minor editorial
uh update recommendation so that the
executive summary
is on or is on all fours with policy 3.2
sustainable housing
outlined on page 27. um with that
members
uh i would like to record thanks to
fenny compton
parish council and its neighborhood
development plan group for the work done
to date
and also to the work done by our
officers to get to this point
and would recommend acceptance of the
recommendation
as outlined on page seven of your papers
thank you
so uh
councillor pemberton has proposed that
some recommendation on page seven
subject to the minor amendment is
mentioned can i have a second to please
thank you councillor cargill uh can i
use
are there any objections to the
recommendation
on page seven in that case
uh the recommendation is agreed thank
you members of cabinet
so without further ado moving on to item
six
the capital budget monitoring period one
two eight
uh councillor harvey uh
thank you leader the purpose of this
paper is to keep
members informed of the progress made
over the first
eight months of the year in undertaking
the council's intended
level of capital expenditure this year
the position in relation to the capital
budget for the year has remained
unchanged since the cabinet last met
table
1 on page 27 demonstrates the intention
to undertake expenditure of 10.7 million
pounds this year
including section 106 projects
taking into account additional funds of
2.9 million pounds budgeted for this
year
this will result in the balance of the
council's accumulated
capital receipts and grants being
reduced over the year
assuming all capital projects budgeted
are to be delivered
from 6.4 million pounds to an overspend
of 1.4 million pounds paragraph
1.5 indicates that capital expenditure
of 1.3 million pounds
has either already been undertaken or
being committed to
by the end of november in the first
eight months of the year therefore
the sums either spent or committed
amount to
12 of this year's available budget
of 10.7 million pounds
appendix 2 on pages 37 to 39
provides summary information concerning
the various projects yet to be funded
through section 106 agreements which as
indicated on page 39
have a total value of 4.5 million pounds
unless cabinet members have any
questions therefore i ask
the current position on capital
expenditure and
income for the eight month period to the
end of november
2020 be noted
are there any questions members of
cabinet
i'll take that as a resounding no so the
recommendation on page 27
uh is everyone in agreement with that oh
sorry
can i have a seconder for the
recommendation on page 27 please
i'll second that thank you in that case
uh unless there are any objections noted
the recommendation on page 27 is carried
thank you moving on item seven
uh revenue budget monitoring once again
councillor harvey
thank you leader the purpose of this
report
is to inform the cabinet of the revenue
picture of the council's finances to the
end of november
2020 i'd like to begin by asking members
to turn to appendix 3
on page 51. this shows that the net
budget to be financed by the council
this year
is 20.8 million pounds
if we now turn to appendix 2 on page 49
we can see that the budget for the whole
year is for total expenditure of
28.4 million pounds and total income
from various sources
of 11.6 million pounds the difference
between these two numbers
therefore is 16.7 million pounds
together with the net cost of benefits
of 186 000 pounds
represents the total amount to be funded
from various sources
i.e that is 16.9 million pounds
as set out in appendix 2.
in addition appendix 2 also sets out
that as a result of the covid 19
pandemic
the council has received civil
contingencies funding
from the government of 43.7 million
pounds
of which 35.5 million pounds has already
been distributed
in ways consistent with the government's
intentions
leaving a balance of 8.2 million pounds
at the end of november
turning to the position at the end of
period 8 we can see that on page 49
that in round terms the council's
expenditure
of 19.9 million pounds was a
816 000 pounds more than budgeted
this reflects a variety of decisions
across the council's activities
in light of our current very changed
circumstances
the impact of the covid19 pandemic
is similarly illustrated in the
shortfall against
budgeted income to the end of november
of 1.2 million pounds
although there were shortfalls in
revenue of 2.3 million pounds
generated from fees charges rents
and interest principally 1.2 million
pounds of budgeted revenue
lost from the district's car parks this
was
offset by over budget receipts of grants
reimbursements and recharges of a
million pounds
the combination of these outcomes means
that the net
cost of all services provided in the
first eight months of the year
excluding the additional net cost of the
payment of benefits
of 472 000 pounds was
2.1 million pounds greater than had been
budgeted
section 4 of the paper identifies the
principal items of variance
from their budgeted figures during the
period april to november
whilst section 5 provides estimates for
the out turn
for the year in fall managers
and heads of service are again to be
commended for providing these estimates
in the face of the continuing
uncertainty surrounding the council's
activities section seven
of the paper demonstrates the severe
strain
that the pandemic is having on the
council's
reserve position which at this stage
is estimated will be reduced from 8.9
million pounds
to 4 million pounds by the end of the
financial year
can i make the obvious point things
can't continue like this unchanged
the council's general fund reserve will
have been reduced
by more than half in a single year
this estimate takes no account of the
impact of the lockdown which began
earlier this month which will have a
further impact
on the council's finances
importantly appendix 4 identifies the
council's current earmarked reserves
as they stood at the end of november
2020.
reallocations of a number of these
earmount earmarked reserves
to the general reserve fund will form
part of the proposals for the 2122
budget
to be considered by the cabinet at its
next meeting
on the 18th of january subject to any
further information that mr
hill might be in a position to provide
about the prospects
for the remainder of the current
financial year and to any other matters
and to any questions members may have i
asked
the report be received
thank you councillor harvey uh i thought
this was a
very sobering report which really does
outline the
impact the curving 19 pandemic
was actually had on the council's
finances
i note in particular uh in paragraph 417
this curvy 19 in civil contingencies
the significant that is actually the
significant impact that has had on
workload
so without further ado uh are there any
questions or any comments from members
of cabinet
i'll take that as a no so
uh in that case uh the recommendations
on page seven
uh can i have a second
gentleman you have some speakers wishing
to speak
oh sorry i didn't see any hands up
in the chat oh sorry i wasn't looking at
the chat uh
castle junior was first chairman okay
councillor junaid yes it's on the
um the item seven revenue budget
monitoring
i did ask um uh george hill and he was
very
good about responding to me about the
estimated out turn position
on off street parking and planning
enforcement
uh which shows shortfalls against budget
of 1.6
million and 0.6 million now i want you
did ask
um how much allowance has been made in
these figures for the promised
government compensation for 75
of losses i had a response um
but i i want to follow up on the
response because
um i am still not clear that the 4.166
million that is the estimated
out turn for the year doesn't include
the 1.102 million compensation
and i would like to have that clarified
and then the
1.102 million uh covers to the end of
november
only and i wondered whether the scheme
was expected to carry on
until the end of the year and if so how
much extra above the 1.102 million
do we expect to get i wonder whether
that could be
clarified please mr hill do you wish to
respond
yes certainly um no the 4 million
deficit doesn't include the government
funding with government funding the
overall deficit is about 2.6 million for
the year um
the sales fees and charges uh
compensation
that council junet is referring to will
continue for the rest of the year
and we've made allowance for that in
fact it the government might have now
said they would like it to continue for
the first quarter of the new year as
well so it will continue right
up to the end of june uh 2021.
so just to finally clarify uh the
figures that we've got in front of us
right now
are not the latest figures we still have
to
uh have a have a further update to bring
them up to
up to currently now they are the latest
figures that the budget monitoring
figures the
um the government funding is shown
separately at the bottom of the pages
and you can see it there but the net
impact is about 2.6 million
on the council's financial position
can i just clarify mr hill that these
are updated every month
yes yeah we have taken many months we've
bring them to cabinet every two months
yeah
okay does that answer our questions
councillor junior
uh i will probably follow up with um mr
hill uh afterwards
that i do have some other questions
which i i think
are probably not appropriate for now but
will be appropriate before the next
report
thank you councillor junior so can i
have a second uh for the recommendations
on page 41 please
thank you councillor parry uh so
are there any objections to the
recommendations on page
41 i'll take that as
no so in that case thank you members of
cabinet the recommendations on
page 41 are accepted so
now we move back to uh item
five on the agenda off street parking
charges
councillor shenton thank you very much
leader and uh
please forgive me if i choke a little
bit i've got a frog in my throat all of
a sudden
um there's recommendations in front of
members of cabinet today but i wish to
withdraw
recommendation number two regarding the
car parks in the main rural centers
it's clear that this is not the right
time to consider this
as as a situation with regards to kobe
19 and the lack of bandwidths available
in terms of offices and staff time has
deteriorated since we first put the
recommendation
forward i am therefore withdrawing
recommendation too at this time
and we will only be discussing
recommendation one today
there are three parts to recommendation
one uh three principal parts the car
parking charges themselves
over 65s permits and other parking
issues to be considered
the increases we're proposing in the
charges are as they were originally
proposed last year and which was
subsequently deferred due to covet 19.
as you would have heard from councillor
harvey's presentation on the financial
position
of the council we are faced with a
growing deficit and therefore we are
faced with a heavy heart of having to
make tough decisions on
what we can afford and how we can bridge
the gap
in our finances this is part and parcel
of a wholesale review of all revenues
and costs
it's essential that we act prudently and
consider all options
i will know the bid of center letter in
asking for us to limit the increases and
in fairness this is what we've already
done
in limited limiting it to inflation
over the eight years since car parking
charges were last reviewed
we've all faced and continue to face
challenging times and in the district
council's case we are trying to maintain
all services whilst reducing costs where
we can
there's only so much that you can do
without also having to consider
increasing revenue by increasing in a
prudent way
charges for some services such as the
provision of car parking
key points of the recommendation are
contained on page 23 in section 2.1
whilst just below that tables 1 and 2
show the current
and the proposed tariffs for town centre
car parks along with permits
and season ticket options on page 25
the evidence base for proposals are
contained in sections
4.1 to 4.4 whilst the financial benefits
are shown is section 6.2
the increases in charges are broadly in
line with the rpi for the eight years
that have passed since charges were
reviewed in particular you will see that
permits for business users have not been
increased as we've
and as we've seen because we're heavily
dependent on hospitality
and been open it's a fair assumption
that many of the cars normally in our
car parks are visitors tourists and
staycationers
and as such the increase in charges will
not have any major if any
effect on tourist numbers for many
residents
it will make no difference as we
continue to offer the first hour for
free
at bridgeway car parks even at one pound
20 per hour some members of bid
themselves have highlighted correctly
that we're still
below many towns similar towns as
ourselves
and i like those members do not believe
that the increase of 20p
will encourage people to go to warwick
levington or sully hall to shop
what does encourage people to travel is
the offering
not reasonable car park charges we do
not take this decision to increase
charges lightly but in the face of our
financial position
our options for raising revenue are very
limited
turning to the over 65 permit last year
i highlighted the over 65 permit
and i'm doing so again there seems to be
a little point in proposing an increase
to say a hundred pounds to bring the
permit in line with witchhaven
or 175 pounds to bring it in line with
wire forest
the only two local councils that offer
this kind of permit
as reaction to the proposed increase to
50 pounds last year was unfavorable
numbers of residents taking this permit
would probably fall dramatically making
this
uneconomical to provide with non-permit
holding council taxpayers subsidizing
the relatively low numbers of permit
holders
the over 65 permit holder is currently
receiving approximately a 97
discount on the car parking charges
this is not equitable for the other
households who have to pay
full parking charge i'd also add that
we've seen numbers taking up this permit
for by over 28 percent in the last year
even though it was left at 10 pounds
i've conducted a separate survey of over
20 other councils
which i'm happy to highlight and apart
from one limited offer in one of the
councils none of these offer
an over 65 permits the proposal to
discontinue this permit will stay in
and go out for consultation
which i in in actual fact i think is the
best way forward i'm thinking here of
the
majority of residents other key changes
in the schedule one particular large
increase is for overnight stays for
large vehicles which has been increased
for 20
pounds and this was to tackle a
particular problem with refrigerated
lorries in one of our car parks
and to discourage them we've raised the
charge significantly and we will review
the situation
regularly we will stop this issue as a
relative peace and quiet of residents
in the vicinity of that area is
important to us
in addition the proposal is that we
should install new card only machines
and cease to take
cash as the cost of collecting cash is
significant
this won't all happen on the 1st of
april
it will be phased in giving everyone the
chance to adjust
but it is right that we move forward
with this transition
we will continue to offer the facility
to pay via phone using ringo or other
providers of the service
the whole pro proposal is subject to a
six-week
consultation period after which we'll
review the
comments and make the final decision
it is right that residents should have a
say on this proposal
and is in line with our commitment to
consult and keep residents
and businesses informed i ask therefore
that members of cabinet consider the
recommendations
on page 23 or consider the
recommendation number one
on page 23 and approve it so we can move
to the public consultation
and give our residents the chance to
review and comment
but i am happy to take any questions on
this
at this point all right thank you very
much
i have counselor junior and councillor
ralph wishing to speak councillor
thank you um first of all can i uh
welcome the
recommendation to is not proceeding
uh and uh i i'll be happy to tell us to
town council that as
and i'm sure um counselor car bill will
as well
um what i am i am worried about
the um the whole aspect
of support for our town centers and i'm
worried about whether or not
this will make things worse our high
streets and businesses have taken a
considerable battering this last year
and i'm just wanting to see a much more
innovative approach to the recovery of
our town centers and high streets
once this pandemic is over and i just
think that simply increasing parking
charges without looking at how
high streets are changing and what local
people and businesses really need for
recovery could be seen as short-sighted
we need to be able to find other ways of
supporting our towns and businesses
more businesses and more visitors when
it's safe to do so
i do know that for example the high
street task force
the center for cities the local
government association
are all making efforts to to look at
how we might support our town centers
and retail
within those town centres the
pandemic is having is showing a
significant reduction in demand for
products and services
from the high streets and many
uh businesses high street businesses are
reducing their presence in the town
centers
and this could have potential negative
long-term consequences
i do know that for example in
stratford-upon-avon i believe there are
now 40
plus uh units that are empty are up for
sale or
uh you know not not no longer uh
trading uh and that is having uh a
detrimental effect on the town and even
when
international tourism comes back uh it
that will have a um a rather downbeats
um you know impression given a downbeat
impression
of the towns now if if you
if the council could uh look more
much more proactively at how we could
avoid a downward spiral
and try to see if they could intervene
in a much more positive way by working
with people
then this is part of an overall picture
by working with the county council on
their parking strategies etc
i could see some sense in that but just
to do one aspect alone
uh without considering uh the impact on
other uh parts of the of the retail
sector um i i just feel that it will it
will be detrimental
so i would like you to reconsider that
think please and
please listen to counselor kate rob
because she uh covers the town which i i
don't actually
thank you thank you councillor rolf
thank you tony um can you hear me
yes firstly i want to mention the 20
increase in parking charges in stratford
district council car parks this is an
increase which is too soon
and too harsh particularly on any
recovery in the town centre
and other towns in the district any
increases should happen later in the
year and only then if we see some upturn
in the local economy
we must also take into consideration
that the on street parking will be
cheaper than off street
this could impact on more cars traveling
through our towns trying to park on the
streets
in order to save money and more so
causing congestion
and unnecessary emissions from vehicles
it could also mean that the county have
to increase their costs to on-street
parking
so that they are more expensive secondly
i want to talk about the over 60s
65s parking permits more and more
older people are using the recreation
ground as part of their exercise routine
either walking using the gym equipment
or walking their dogs
more and more older people use the
facilities in the town banks building
societies
m s etcetera using the free one-hour
parking at the bridge foot car park
doesn't give older people enough time to
do what they want
these are a group of people who will
when the facilities are open
use the cafes and restaurants as well as
the local shops
abolishing this permit is a retrograde
step
and will have an impact on the football
in our town
increasing the cost i'm sure will allow
more use
of the facilities i don't understand why
this council having agreed in 2019
to increase the charge to 25 pounds are
going back on their word
and abolishing it all together it's
another nail in the coffin for the
vibrancy of our town
center surely over doubling the cost
will bring in more money to the council
rather than dismissing the permit
entirely
i'm fully aware of the financial
position this council is in but people
will be facing
an increase in council tax the cost of
the green bin
and potentially an increase in parking
and for a certain cohort
losing their parking permits older
people's savings are being impacted
hugely don't take this one benefit away
from them
the county and district are working on a
parking strategy
and i believe we should wait until the
result of this parking strategy
to decide whether we should increase our
parking or not
and take away the 60 over 65's parking
permit
or not i am concerned about how much
notice that you will give to the
residents of our town
in response to the consultation if it's
overwhelmingly against are you going to
go back on your decision thank you
thank you councillor ralph i think
there's been some very interesting
points made about the town center
i think the town center uh regeneration
is going to be a huge task i don't think
we've seen the end yet
of the impact of the kirby pandemic
i have to say that i think car parking
charges are a minor issue
compared to an awful lot of the other
issues with town centres
uh it is not going to be easy to
revitalize town
centers i think picking up the points
that are being made we have to take some
very difficult decisions
about the car about the council finances
it's not only looking at one year it's
looking at over a five-year period
and the reality actually is we have to
produce a budget that balances
and this is one way of doing it and we
have few levers available
to actually balance the budget
this is one i see no one else
wishing to speak councillor pemberton
and then councillor shenton
thank you very much leader i think i
would just make a number of
observations um both councillors junid
and rolf
reference work with the county council
um we are north of 12 months waiting for
work from the county council around a
parking strategy
no indication of any imminent movement
from the county council on that
piece of work what we do have
in front of us is an imminent budget
problem um cancer roth
notes that on the one hand um
pensioners uh avail themselves of the
permit
to use the wreck which to be absolutely
honest
has no economic upside benefit
whatsoever
to the town if you go to walk your dog
and you take your dog home you don't
spend any money in the town
um the notion that we should
um continue to support this
in a in a in a position where the
alternate
choices are around
diminution of services and loss of jobs
um for a uh a
a 97 and a half percent discount
let's just be clear about that we are
suggesting that one group should have a
97 and a half percent discount on the
parking rates
which even members of the bid
acknowledge are not
exorbitant um over and above that
um if we are going to do that how
should we not address the number of
minimum wage workers
who have to pay every day to park in the
town
and we're in essence taxed on the tax on
on coming to work
um we don't do that we can't afford
to do that um we are not in a position
to be able to
you know support privilege to be honest
you know we are we ask you know
if one can afford to run a car one can
afford to pay more than two and a half
percent of the going right for car
parking
and um you know we either we know we
can't increase it to the
to the absolute rate that it should be
that others so we should end the thing
and we all then have to share the burden
and there is a burden to be to be shared
i'm afraid
with recovery and this is file under
difficult
unfortunately not very popular things
that we
are going to have to do if we are going
to ensure this authority
continues to deliver the services that
residents including pensioners want us
to deliver
so i i will support um councillor
shenton's proposals around this
and i'm happy to defend the rationale
for so doing
thank you councillor pemberton
councillor shenton
thank you leader um in actual fact
council of pemberton has
stolen a lot of my thunder one one thing
please
please don't feel you need to repeat it
no no
one thing i will i will say is that um
on on this matter is that there's two
things actually
two things in the liberal democrats own
manifesto they say that money spent by
councils must be spent prudently
and they also say they would support
prudent measures to increase the income
of the council this is what prudency
looks like these
increase in charges and the removal
of this permit i don't know i only know
of one
other liberal democrat council out of 26
that uh they control where they have
such a permit so it's not that this is
generally available
anywhere locally or anywhere else
and the second thing i note that a
number of people
declared an interest in this um and
i i'm wondering whether everyone has
declared an interest in this especially
uh i noticed susan's unit the council's
unit has declared an interest but
i don't know whether you have an
interest a beneficial interest
in this yourself cancer off and surely
that should be declared as well
if you have can i make it clear that i
have no interest because i have no
permit
no i had that's what i'm saying cancer's
unit i can see that
but can i make it clear i don't have a
permit either
is there a permit at the household
though
yes there is my husband has one so there
is a beneficial interest
so i think that should be that should
have been noted
just bring me one second i declare an
interest then sure
if i may but my thank you
my overriding comment on all this is
that these increases
are fair there is nothing unfair about
them
it will not drive tourism away it will
not do
it's not doom and gloom like you painted
cancer involved
of driving football away from the town
that will not
happen so i would ask uh
capita whilst your comments are noted
it's right you should go out to
consultation at a house cabinet
to now proceed to
vote on this thank you thank you uh can
i have a seconder for the
uh proposal please
thank you councillor harvey
chairman sorry can i just check
what one comment or well two things if i
may
chairman before we go to the vote
firstly the
comments in chat should be restricted to
indicating that you wish to speak
that said i know councillor pena donald
represented the osc has had trouble
this afternoon and before you just moved
to the vote i just wanted to relay
some of the concerns from the overview
and scrutiny committee um
in relation to the proposals they
they're related to
elderly more elderly users you've been
used to ask you
pay by card predominantly but also the
impact of removing the permits for the
elderly from the residents
using the town from overall villages so
i just wanted to make sure the comments
were
at least input into the debate the the
second point i just wanted to
confirm before moving to the vote the
the recommendation is published says
that the proposed chain
charges to the car park parish and
parking permit as outlined in this
report be agreed in full
you you you've just mentioned
consultation
can i just confirm that that is subject
to consultation
and it will come back to the committee
following a period of consultation
i thought david we had to do the
consultation anyway
yeah i just just wanted to be absolutely
yeah
as well yes there's so
so obviously in the um in the
legal implications part it's clarified
that there is a statutory
consultation but what i've heard
and i may be mistaken here but what i
thought i'd heard from uh councillor
shenton in proposing
it was that there was the recommendation
one itself was going to be subject to
a public consultation in other words
that he was going to come back to
cabinet
afterwards it's the statutory congress
just be clarified please one way or the
other yeah it's a statutory consultation
there's normal six-week statutory
consultation
that i'm referring to so that so the
wording of resolution
recommendation one remains as it is yeah
that's that's correct yes okay thank you
and the points you raised
from penano donald noted david thank you
uh so uh sorry did i get a seconder for
this
yes thank you councillor harvey uh
in that case do any members of cabinet
uh object to the proposals on page
the proposal on page 23
no in that case thank you members of
kevin
uh recommendation one on page 23
is agreed so we now
move on to
item five on the agenda
the uk resettlement scheme councillor
barker
sorry just had to throw a puppy off my
lap
and she took the paperwork off with her
so um the uk resettlement scheme
item eight um was set up
uh and as work undertaken to house and
or re
and or resettle syrian vulnerable people
um between 2015 and 2020
um and to consider the resettlement of
12 refugee households
under the revised scheme for 2021 to
2025.
this has been a successful scheme
and i think it's something that we as
stratfor district
have shot at more importantly
under the current circumstances
this is largely funded and
funded more so than last time
via the partnership and the county
council
and more voluntary and community sector
agencies are there to support refugees
i'd like you to note that um people have
to reside in the uk for at least five
years after this and then they can apply
for indefinite leave to remain
it's an ongoing commitment by the
government to do this
do also note that um the nationalities
of the refugees we settled may
change in response to world events and i
think it's very important for us to
recognize that but that under the
current circumstances
um we are looking at the resettlement
process for syrians largely
um the there was an agreement
in uh march pretty much just as the
covid
epidemic started um i think the 13th of
march where
um the portfolio decision agreed that we
would have 12 families
now we are bringing forward the further
resettlement to 12 families 2021 to 25.
um and if you look at um
page 57 item 6.1
um we've successfully supported 12
families over the past four years
and we think that we can do it again um
added to which there are more resources
being thrown in from
other places so it will not have the
same constraint on our own offices
so there are no
questions in particular may i
put the recommendation to you that
we uh note the work that has been
undertaken
in the 2015-2020 scheme and
we agree to resettle 12 refugee
households
um that needs amending to refugee rather
than refuge households i notice
under the revised uk resettlement scheme
between 2021 and 2025.
thank you thank you councillor barker
can i have a second ear for the
recommendations on page
55 please thank you councillor parry
uh are there any objections from members
of cabinet
no thank you members of cabinet the
recommendations are carried
so moving on agenda item nine the local
industrial and economic development
strategy action plan
uh councillor jennings
thank you very much leader uh you have
the report
and would have read it so i'll try not
to repeat too much
obviously we have a background here with
the effects the pandemic on our economy
now and over the next few years are
going to be devastating
the decline of the high streets has been
going on for years the pandemic
has accelerated this town centers will
have to change and adapt
this is not unique to stratford and is
national
and no one has come up with an easy
solution
we're the fourth hardest hit council in
the country
the motor industry has published
terrible economic results
and as are the medium term forecasts and
over 40 percent of our workforce are on
furlough
to sum it up times are hard um with this
report
um in these difficult times our offices
have achieved great strides
in the local industrial and economic
strategy action plan
of the 35 objectives in total 23 of
these look like they'll be going green
in the next six months
in fact i think two of the yellow
statuses a 3.8
and 8 3.10 have both already gone green
since december it's quite remarkable
and i'd like to commend the officers on
their outstanding work
i'd also like to add stratfor have
ambitious plans
which are already moving forward such as
the riverside corridor project
the canal quarter regeneration when i've
recently visited the british car music
car museum which is amazing and has
ambitious plans to expand
the same with the dallas burst and polo
more collaboration with warwick district
will also help
businesses recognize the district as
ambitious
we welcome lotus we continue to develop
our relationships with the west midlands
combined
authority and coventry and warwickshire
local enterprise partnership
this gives us a voice and a seat at the
big table
cabinet the recommendation is that the
progress made to deliver the objectives
of the local industrial and economic
development strategy
is noted and the updates to the action
plan are set out in appendix one
are endorsed thank you councillor
jennings i see no one
uh wishing to speak i would just sorry
councillor junaid
yes i did indicate in the chat that i
wanted to speak
um i i just want to pick up on the ones
that are expected the
the
not yet completed may not be complete
within six months
items one of which was the the district
council to bid for towns
for funds for town centers at national
and regional levels
uh such as from the west midland
combined authority
pilot study and that is clusters
progress expected
uh as i understand it one bit when
went in for studlytown center but that
was quite some time ago
and and i don't know that of any other
uh that have been made
since then of the other ones that are
progress expected could you please
uh give me some indication maybe not
at this meeting but afterwards uh on
exactly when that progress will be
expected
uh and also perhaps as the leader of the
opposition group
keep me informed as to when uh some of
that work is being
done i would like to make sure that for
example that
um the liaison about the role of smaller
towns to strengthen their tourism offer
is is um is emphasized and also
that um that the work done on
facilitating um to prevent congestion on
on roads
and also
know that i am fully up to date on the
strategic housing market
assessment uh and so that i can see what
is being done
uh that is um that one was uh a 3.4
carry out a strategic housing market
assessment because i i saw
one councillor one wondering where that
was but it is in that risk
thank you very much indeed thank you
councillor junior
uh do you wish to respond to any of
those
council jennings yes councillor junior
i'll certainly come
come back to you and update youtube i'll
liaise with you and if there are any
specifics uh which i can assist you with
and
give you further information i will
certainly do so
thank you uh councillor cargill you wish
to speak
thank you leader yeah i just wanted to
make a comment really
this is an ambitious work program and
liaison with
a number of partners and i just wanted
to
go back to the comment that was made
that the parking charges were
looked at in isolation they're not
this is a part of a grand scheme to try
and regenerate the entire district
and it's not just one part of it is the
parking judge is one small part of it
and this this ambitious program working
with people
developers industries etc is designed to
try
and get the district back onto its feet
again now the high street is another
matter altogether
we do need to work hard on that one
there's no doubt about it
but that is a national problem so all i
just wanted to say is uh i think this is
a grand scheme thank you very much
indeed for being to the
uh the cabinet uh council jennings and
uh
no go for it i'll happily second it
thank you councillor cargill i think you
made some very good points
and very welcome point as well
councillor kettle
um just a brief point um mr chairman
um absolutely concur with all the points
that the portfolio holders raised
but just for completeness um
within that section a 3.12 13 and 15
um the report relates to the
agricultural industry
and whilst um that doesn't benefit me
any
any more than any other farmer in the
district i should just declare
uh to mr grafton um a
a potential con interest in that in that
item uh just for completeness
as a member of the agricultural
community
thank you councillor kettle uh
councillor harvey
do you wish to speak i do thank you
chairman
um i don't have any difficulty
supporting uh councillor jennings's
work and this recommendation i do note
however
in paragraph right at the beginning
paragraph 1.1
it is set out that the council will work
with partners and local businesses
to deliver jobs and economic growth
across the district can i ask that
when we receive the next report
in relation to this strategy the
implementation of this strategy
that some information some data is
included
which illustrates the number of jobs
and the degree of economic activity
growth
which is attributable to the work that
councillor jennings is overseeing
please thank you councillor harvey
a very interesting point and i think one
that is well worth making and we ought
to capture
the results of the work that we actually
do i i have to say that i suspect an
awful lot of the
of the results will not just be as a
result of this council's actions
but actually working with the lep
the west midlands combined authority and
others
because that more and more seems to be
the way in which
uh the really big projects actually end
up on our doorstep
so uh with that i think this was both
proposed
and seconded so
are there any objections to the
recommendation on page 59 members of
cabinet
i'll take that as a no so in that case
the recommendation is accepted
so we now move on to issues arising from
overview and scrutiny there are none
from cabinet committees none and the on
block items the housing investment panel
minutes they
are just for noting i've been notified
of no
urgent business so i therefore
thank all members for attending uh thank
you for some good discussion
and i now declare the meeting closed
thank you
thank you
you